yeah this one this is gold
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today in 2021 i'm a registered architect
in the state of western australia
and i have a pretty good idea of what
architects do from a day-to-day basis
so today we're going to be looking at
stock photos of what the world
perceives to be an architect now i've
seen some of these come through already
and some of them are quite hilarious
some of them are pretty close to what we
do
but let's go through them one by one so
the first photo is pretty much on the
money which is a good thing we started
here
it's a guy with a couple overlooking a
set of plans
on what appears to be their back patio
very common
probably an alteration edition project
looking at making this house
the absolute best house they can and the
house of their dreams
no this just doesn't happen don't even
get your hopes up
well this bloke is probably me in about
40 years
but i don't think anybody's at a
drafting board anymore i think drafting
boards have gone out the window a long
long time ago
so i'm surprised they still even depict
architects as
sitting down and drawing at an architect
board alright this next photo
is a surveyor standing next to what
appears to be an architect
i don't know how many projects you have
the surveyor out on unless it's a very
very large project
and usually i'd like to take a good stab
in the dark of this photo and think it's
the surveyor telling the architect where
things need to go
and not the other way around because at
the end of the day
they're the ones that should be
interpreting your drawings and
understanding
exactly where bits and pieces need to go
so the next one again pretty good
indication of what an architect does
from a day-to-day
it is sitting at a computer drawing
models drawing 3d plans
and coming up with the vision that your
client really really wants
so that's actually a really good
representation of what an architect does
this bloke this bloke seems like he's
gone through a bit got his model in
front of him
big cup of coffee palette material
around
desks papers brochures the works
it looks like he's in for a long night
and that's
that's common still the model not so
much we don't really model
well we don't really physically model
make too much anymore in architecture
especially if you're a smaller firm
the budget doesn't really allow for that
so if you're going to charge a client to
do a 3d model like that that's going to
charge
three four days of work it's probably
not worth it and you don't get enough
value out of it
so that's probably a good representation
of how stressed and busy we are
but not what we actually spend our time
on this next one
is a really nice office first of all
doesn't happen
there's not a single desk in the random
giant space
filled with natural light one very
expensive couch
in the background and just a random
person working at a desk
maybe a home maybe work from home
situation seems legit
but not your general office presenting
on an ipad with a pin up
again probably not too common anymore
especially if you're presenting to
clients you'd probably have it up on a
screen or just at your ipad or just on a
printout
you don't actually pin up on a board per
se too often anymore
so i know we're very used to that at
university where you pin up you present
you talk through your project
that doesn't really happen so that's
probably more of a university level than
an actual realistic level this bloke
just looks like he's made a very seedy
deal
in the back of some construction site
now
one bloke's got a hard hat on no vest no
goggles
no earmuffs they're the bloke no
protection whatsoever that's just real
bad construction etiquette there
these two i don't know what these two
are doing one lady is just pointing to a
extremely outdated screen that's
completely black
this bloke appears to be writing on top
of a folder
with what appears to be a sharpie
there's two hard hats in the background
a measuring tape just thrown on the desk
a lamp that appears like it was bought
in ikea in 1912
that's the most outdated architectural
photo ever just they've
just thrown some architectural bits and
pieces in there no relevance
now one bloke standing with a set of
plans on what appears to be a farm
well at least he's got his vest on he's
got his hard hat on
can't comment on the boots seems legit
i'll give him that one seems legit yeah
this one this is gold this is how i feel
90 of the time you go and finish
something somebody comes around and they
just want to change it so you just want
to smash everything
that's that's pretty fair two guys on a
site one guy holding his hard hat
so he's clearly doesn't care and he's
pointing with his measuring tape
to the drawing i've been on a lot of
construction sites
i've spoken to a lot of people i've
spoken a lot of builders
not once has this happened to me i could
be wrong it might happen
but it doesn't happen this one's just
dumb like
there's three people sitting inside a
very clean office
with hard hats on
i don't know that's no
four people construction site hard hats
that's a bit better
this guy this guy looks like nabeel if
you have no idea who nabeel is i'm gonna
drop his
instagram right here he's a pretty like
i don't know famous photographer i guess
he's pretty good
but that's that's the bill inside hard
hat
no though so there's definitely some
accurate information out there and some
very unaccurate information
if you're looking to become an architect
do your research understand what we do
all day every day and see if you can do
that because the perception of what
architects do
and don't do is very very vast as we
found out today that's all from me today
guys thanks so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below
and as always well at least this month
i will see you tomorrow